i had a buddy
that his name was sean mims out of los
angeles
i had taught him how to do tax return
fraud
i told sean i go missing right i go
missing for three months i told him if i
ever went missing not to contact me
and
so i go missing then i show back up
online
first day he contacts so he becomes a
target and they identify him pretty
quickly at that point
he's set to be arrested sometime in
march of uh
of six that's when he's said to be
arrested
operation rolling stone was the name of
the operation nine people were supposed
to be arrested that night so secret
service
goes in a re goes and arrests this guy
they search his apartment and don't find
anything
the apartment manager comes out and
explains to him how sean has done all
kinds of work to the apartment as a
matter of fact he brought in thirty
thousand dollars worth of italian tile
to put in the apartment that he's
renting and by the way last night he had
a u-haul out here and took out a whole
shitload of stuff
secret service comes back in
they look at me and they're like we need
you to take a polygraph
and my answer was
i ain't taking a polygraph
so they're like well we'll throw you
back in jail if you don't i was like
call my lawyer lawyer gets me on the
phone he's like
you don't have to take the polygraph i
was like well good i'm not going to he's
like but they will throw you back in
jail i was like don't want to do that
he's like
have you done anything i was like
yeah and he's like
well you can try to pass the polygraph
i'm like okay
so i was like let's take the polygraph
they asked three questions the questions
were uh
have you talked to anybody
have you have you been on a computer
outside of the offices have you talked
to the press which i was interviewing
with a new york times writer the entire
time and then have you contacted or
warned anybody about investigations and
i failed polygraph completely
so they revoked the bond
took me back down to charleston county
throw me into jail
three days later
secret service shows back up
and uh pulled me out of a cell it's jim
ramacan and bobby kirby and they were i
mean honestly i i
they were good men
and they gave me chances upon chances to
do the right thing and
i was not ready to do that and uh
jim ramacone and bobby's in there and
bobby i mean bobby was a friend
i mean truly was i later on a couple
years ago i had a chance to uh
a couple years ago i had a chance to uh
to have lunch with a man and uh
told him i was sorry for everything i
did to him because i got him and him and
another agent fired
and uh
told him i was sorry for what happened
and uh
he told me then he's like we were your
friends man we were truly your friends
so they were good they wanted to help
yeah
they weren't they wanted you to be a
good man yeah yeah what what got me
today i'm bad is uh
i told him i was like man i'm trying to
be a better guy
and uh he's like brett you always were a
good guy you just didn't know it
and uh [ __ ] people like that yes we need
people like that in this world yeah
you need somebody to basically believe
oh man that you can be a good man
so uh jim ramachan pulls me out he's the
second in charge in charge of south
carolina he's got the miranda waiver
in front of him right and he looks at me
he's like
i'm playing hard ass bobby's over here
looking distraught and you know like a
hurt dog
and jim's like
here's the way this is going to work he
said you're going to tell me everything
you've done the past six years i'm going
to make it my mission in life to [ __ ]
over you
and your family and he said not just
this case once you get out of prison
i'll hound you the rest of your life
then he slides the miranda waiver over
and he's like now you want to talk
and i looked at him i was like
nope
he was like
he gets up gets all red in the face
storms out as on the way out he's like
[ __ ] you very much
so i go back to the cell a week later i
was on only under under state charges a
week later judge
rules they revoke the bond improperly
wow oh
reinstates the bond nobody calls the
secret service to tell them i walk out
i walk out i was dating the stripper and
i i told my mom i was like well
if they're going to [ __ ] me they're
going to have to find me
she just went on the move yeah i i
called this stripper girl up i'd given
her like 60k some [ __ ] like that
and
i told her i was like kim i need some
money and she was like
what i was like look i said give me a
thousand dollars
i'll give you back three thousand
dollars in two weeks she's like okay so
i met her in augusta georgia
and uh
got the thousand from her and started
driving west on i-20
no idea where to go to anything else got
to dallas
there was a prepaid debit card supplier
in dallas went in walked in the office
convinced the guy social engineering
convinced the guy to give me 60 prepaid
debit cards without a driver's license
without payment anything else he did
and
that started the run i ended up stealing
from that i stole like 160k profit used
that to buy a jeep cherokee
and
well the idea was to steal enough money
to bug out to uh florianopolis brazil
and set up shop down there
and
do it again that was the dream that was
it that was it so uh
i was on the run for four months still
six hundred thousand dollars
i was in las vegas nevada one day i had
stolen the night before i stole 160 k
out of atms
went in the next the next morning i woke
up signed on to carter's market dot com
which was ran by max butler the iceman
and there's my name us most wanted on it
and
that gets you attention
it was my real name with the us most
wanted beside of it nobody knew my real
name in that environment at all
but then they did
and it was talking about me being part
of the secret service
operation anglerfish everything else
so of course they're all they're all
like everybody's after they're like oh
yeah we're going to get this son of a
[ __ ]
so i sit there looking at it and i was
like said it out loud i was like well mr
johnson you've made the united states
most wanted list what do you do now and
i was like
i'm going to disney world
literally literally literally said that
out loud
so loaded up the jeep
drove from las vegas to orlando florida
and uh
got the two annual passes one to disney
world the other one to universal studios
paid
paid for a time share they were building
these new time shares
right off universal drive building these
brand new time shares
paid for a time share nine months cash
yeah i was like we take cash yeah we
take cash there's twelve thousand nine
hundred dollars
then it wasn't furnished so i went down
to a furniture store bought thirty
thousand dollars in furniture they had
seized a dvd collection of mine worth
thirty grand bought that back
and proceeded to go to disney world
every day and that lasted about
six weeks
they used a trigger fish this is what
they use nowadays it's called a stingray
um
to find me
so one day i was uh it was like 10 30 in
the morning on saturday september 16th
was the day 2006. so yeah 2006 september
16th
i was used to the builders coming around
knocking making sure everything was all
right so i was asleep
heard this knock at the door
and uh get up look through the keyhole
nobody's there you know the people
nobody's there i was like huh
open the door step out into the hallway
walking down the hall as bobby kirby
another south carolina guy and a uh
orlando orange county cop and they turn
around and they're like hey brett i'm
like hey bobby how are you and it's like
we're good how are you and i'm like i'm
fine would you like to come in
he was like let's put you in cuffs first
and i was like that's probably a good
idea
he's like have you got anything in here
and i was like yeah there's 120 000 in
the bedroom and he was like seriously i
was like yeah that in an ak-47
his face goes white he's like you've got
a rifle and i was like no i'm kidding
with you
he was like he was like okay
so
they throw me in jail in orange county
and
they give me diesel therapy
and diesel therapy is
it took like two weeks
to transport me from orange county
orlando to columbia south carolina and
what happens is you stop at every county
jail you possibly can
go through the processing which is about
six hours
once you get to your bunk hey time to
transport you
they
they do that on purpose on purpose on
purpose wears you down mentally and
physically and everything
i get to uh columbia south carolina now
while i was at orange county what
happens is this inmate because we were
in federal holding this inmate he looks
at me his name was yeti
and he's like hey man you know the only
time you get off in federal prison is
the drug program i was like well man i
don't use drugs and he's like
you can find a drug problem get you and
i was like
i can find a drug problem
so what happens is every county jaw i
stop at on the way to colombia i tell
them i'm alcoholic
and cocaine
so by the time i get to columbia south
carolina they've got this paper trail of
mr johnson requesting help for drugs
i had hired strom thurman's son
as an attorney
they make me drop him because i paid for
him with illegal funds so they give me a
public defender he gets a psychological
evaluation order for me
so psychologist comes in county jail
four hour interview about halfway
through he looks at me as like use any
type of drugs i was like yeah he's like
what do you use cocaine smoker snort
snort how much an eight ball day
that's a lot yeah
do you have any trouble out of that
yeah
i can't get an erection
and he looks at me and i'm looking at
him like
because i had gotten that [ __ ] from
boogie nights
and finally i'm like is that right and
he was like it could happen i was like
okay
so
that makes it into
my pre-sentence report so all federal
inmates
probation office and prosecutor they do
this detailed background check
to basically tell the judge how much
time to give you all right so that drug
bit with that interview makes it into
the psr
so day of interview
i mean day of sentencing i had pled
guilty day of sentencing
there was the prosecutor he stands up
and this this dude is screaming at this
point and he's like mr johnson's
manipulated the secret service he's
manipulated the prosecutor then he
points at the judge
and he's manipulating you today your
honor we insist on the upper limits of
the guidelines well i've been telling
everybody in the jail that if they give
me any more than 60 months i am not
staying
so they were like okay sure
so the judge
looks at me and she's like i agree i'm
like
she said 75 months
so i looked at my lawyer and i was like
uh
can you get the drug program for me he's
like i don't know i'll ask so he stands
up
your honor will you order the drug
program from mr johnson the judge says
no
but i'll recommend he gets evaluated so
the secret service had told her hey he's
full of [ __ ] yeah so she's like no but i
recommend he gets evaluated i looked at
my lawyer and i was like what does that
mean he was like you're probably not
going to get it and i was like
how soon can you get me to the camp and
he was like well if you don't appeal i
can get you there pretty quick my exact
words were [ __ ] the appeal
get me to the camp i'll take it from
there he looks at me like i'm the
biggest idiot in the world
i get sent to because you get a camp
recommended
i have friends family members
look for camps that don't have a fence
around them and we settle on ashland
kentucky
six weeks later i'm in ashland kentucky
and uh pull up there 14 foot fence razor
wire on top and i'm like
i don't climb fences so i go in first
question i ask is are there any jobs
outside of the fence and he was like uh
guard's like well you can work in the
national forest and i'm like no i'll die
out there
he was like well you could do
landscaping i'm like i can run a weed
eater
two days later i walk into the
landscaping office and the cop this is
this this genius of some of these people
and institutions the cop behind his desk
the entire wall
is a blown-up photo
of the compound and the outline area so
i can literally sit there and plot
where i'm going
all right
my dad
i hadn't spoken to that man
in years
and uh he shows up at my sentencing
and stands up in front of the judge and
he's like your honor
i want to make sure brett gets a good
start he can live with me when he gets
out everything else looking back the man
meant that
and
i just thought it was [ __ ] at the
time
so he starts to visit me in prison
i mean yeah in prison he starts to visit
and uh
about the third visit in he looks at me
he's like
i've been reading about you online i was
like yeah he's like yeah
he's like that's a lot of money you made
and i was like yeah
he's like
you think you can teach somebody how to
do that
and i'm like
so what i used to say and again that
it's this i it's this thing of you know
really coming to terms with things what
i used to say was
is i thought my dad
was back in my life
and he was just trying to use me
all right
the truth of the matter was is that my
dad hadn't really seen me
except in that that frame of crime you
know being that criminal
with my mom
everything else i really think that's
how the man was trying to communicate
with me
he wanted to connect with you in the
places where you know where you love
what you're interested in right where
your addiction is essentially and what i
did
is i manipulated the man
and helped me escape
so i agreed to teach him how to do tax
fraud and in return he had the only
money he had to his name he had four
thousand dollars cash
so i manipulated him and he gave me that
and to drop me off a change of clothes a
cell phone and a driver's license the
only driver's license he had was my
driver's license brett johnson
so
i was at the camp for uh i don't know
six eight weeks
and the hardest worker that landscaping
had ever seen
at one point the cops got me on a
mountainside with a broom sweeping off
the mountain i'm like yeah we'll do that
absolutely
so building trust to the guys that go
there yeah working mass off yeah and
within six weeks i'd take off and
i lasted i think two three weeks
something like that u.s marshals i made
it hundreds of you escaped yes escaped
escaped u.s marshals they're canvassing
a three-state area they find me i think
250 miles away it's like lexington
kentucky they found me in lexington
because i had to use my real driver's
license i had a laptop i had prepaid
debit cards and i had stolen identity
information and
kind of the way it got me was i dyed my
hair this flaming red you know i had
this deep tan i didn't look anything
like myself
and uh
i was at a hotel had to have the
curtains open
saw the scout
i was on the laptop saw this guy walk by
he walks by the window
and he stops
and then he backs up he looks inside he
knocks on the window
i look up at him he's like you i was
like me and he's like you then he pulls
out this badge and he points at he's
like
and then he points at the door now
so i was like oh okay so i opened up the
door he's like u.s marshals service
so they arrest me and uh how did they
track you down they canvassed that area
they talked to every hotel everything
else
i had so it's like uh traditional like
their traditional policework is what it
was so it wasn't like from the internet
they kind of got something just just
straight good good us are outstanding
yeah everything they do
so they arrest me i go to a
i'm initially held at a county jail in
moorhead kentucky
and uh that's bad that was one hell of
an experience there
but then i'm transferred after
sentencing on that so sentencing here's
the weird thing
so i spent like uh i think two or three
months at the county jail
in moorhead kentucky
get sentenced at my sentencing
it happened so quickly after the initial
sentencing that they used the exact same
pre-sentence report the report that's
got all that drug [ __ ] in there
so i'm a sentencing
prosecutor's there secret service is
there
judge
me and my attorney
prosecutor stands up he's like your
honor
we would like it if you would consider
that when mr johnson was arrested he had
a laptop he had all this information
with him looks like he was engaged in
identity theft yet again
judge looks at the prosecutor says no
says hey if you were going to charge him
with it you should have charged him with
it i'm only considering the escape then
he looks at me he's like mr johnson
he said it looks like by you keeping
your mouth shut right now
you're really saving yourself a pretty
serious charge and my response was yes
your honor
and he was like then he opens up the
pre-sentence report he's fingering
through and he's like it also looks like
before you got involved with all these
drugs
you were a pretty good citizen i was
like
yes your honor
and he's like so here's what i'm going
to do he said i'm going to give him
18 months on the escape i was like okay
he said i'm also going to give you i was
15 months on this escape so i'm going to
give you 15 months on this game he said
and i'm also going to order the drug
program for you
i was like
yes your honor
so the drug program
gives you a year off
and it gives you six months and halfway
house
so by escaping i got out of prison three
months earlier than what i should have
gotten out of
so the original thing about drugs worked
in the long run now now the long term
the interesting thing with that and
that's the best lie ever told honestly
the best lie ever told
i spent eight months in solitary
confinement
okay eight months
and that's an experience
because you ain't got no books for the
first month or so then they give you a
king james bible
bible yeah
and then
for a month no books
this is a pretty small and six by nine
room six by nine yeah
no books no books no paper no pen no
pencils you're alone with your mind you
got a mat a toilet
what's that like
it's you sleep as much as you can
you're sleeping 16 18 hours a day is
what you're doing talk about that were
you thinking about um
even just going back to like elizabeth
you think you go through all that the
whole thing all that every bit your mom
too yeah going through every single bit
of that and uh
so you're supposed to get out an hour a
day uh law says you're supposed to get
out an hour a day that's the law that's
not the way things actually happen what
actually happens is you're lucky to get
out an hour a week
you take a shower twice a week
and that's that's it you get a phone
call once a month oh so you don't get to
see nature don't see anything you're
getting solitary
all right and uh takes about a week
the first week is the roughest
you're bouncing off the walls that first
week because you can't sleep you can't
do anything else then you start to adapt
to it after a while
when that book does arrive you're happy
as hell to have it i'm well versed in
the king james bible
so
you're happy to have it then finally you
get other books that are coming that
come in from that point um spent eight
months at that
and uh they send me out to a real prison
uh big spring texas west texas
where
prairie dogs and tarantulas yeah that's
what it is it got no kidding it gets so
hot
that uh warnings come on the radio radio
telling you not to drive on certain
streets because they're melted
that's that's big spring
so if you've seen the movie uh
uh from dusk till dawn the opening scene
is in big spring texas
that uh so it's hot
very hot so and that's where i find out
what a real prison is and uh it's not
ran by guards
prisons are run by inmates and that's a
fact so
you're met at the door
by whatever race you are
is what happens so big spring is a
converted air force compound it's a
disciplinary prison so you get the bad
guys are in there
so i get
i go through processing
and i'm walking up to the unit and i met
at the door
by a guy named nick sanderfer he's the
treasurer of the aryan brotherhood and
uh
first question out of his mouth is any
more white guys come in and [ __ ] i
didn't know i was like i don't know four
or five
next question is
what are you in here for
my answer was because i'm like i got no
worries my answer was computer crime
smiled at him
and it turns out wrong thing to say
because computer crime is not credit
card theft or hacking or any [ __ ]
like that computer crime in prison
is child pornography
so tell him that he looks at me like i'm
a piece of [ __ ]
goes and gets his buddies they circle
around
what are you in here for i like how the
aryan brotherhood has like
lines they're like oh yeah yeah this is
the child porn
that's it that's the bad guy they circle
rather like what did you say you're in
here for
so i'm sitting there trying to explain
it to them
they're like you know you tell a good
story you still said this
now computer crime basically really does
mean
usually child pornography in prison yeah
yeah yeah and what you see and that's
one thing you find out that the guys
that are going in there for child porn
they will tell them it's credit card
theft
right so
yeah right they've learned so i'm that
guy but you also don't i mean for people
who are just listening to this you don't
exactly look
like the typical computer hacker that's
true that's true that's very true but i
don't look like the pedophile either
that's right
that's right but it's like it doesn't
make it seem like you're i mean i guess
you're not wearing a a hoodie and you're
you're not like
emo dark
the way it actually works in prison
they won't attack you
until they know
all right so they have to see paperwork
which now in federal prison you don't
get transported with paperwork because
of that
so they have to see paperwork or a guard
will tell them what you're in there for
guards will tell who the menopause are
so
none of the guards told them that was
anything so for the first month they
think i am but they're not doing
anything because they don't know for
sure at the end of the first month i had
been talking to kevin poulsen over at
wired magazine about max butler
he does an article about that shows up
in wired magazine so at the end of the
first month wired magazine hits compound
front cover all the story you would
think you would think it saved me so i'm
reading the article really happy about
it
so what happens is four o'clock is mail
call four o'clock's a stand-up count
nationwide after four o'clock is your
mail call they hand out all the mail for
the day so the mail comes i get the
magazine i'm like reading through i'm
like well [ __ ] i'm good to go
then it says
brett johnson secret service informant
in the article
so you're now snitch
which is right up there with the
pedophiles
so
we go to dinner after that at dinner you
can hear it you can hear the channel we
got a snitch i think it's that guy over
there
warden next day shuts down the entire
compound calls me into his office they
got security there got the counselors
there and everything else warden looks
at me he's like
did you give an interview to wired
magazine i'm like yeah he's like do you
not know they will kill you in here i
was like he was like he was like do you
feel safe
well i know if you tell me you don't
feel safe
they transport you transport you means
another eight months in solitary
confinement you start to see [ __ ] in
solitary after a while yeah so i'm like
no not going to do that so i'm like
completely safe he was like look he's
like
if anybody says anything to you
immediately come to us
because they'll [ __ ] kill you
so they do a locker search try to
confiscate the magazines they can't the
next day i walk into the unit there's
nick sanders laying on his bunk magazine
wide open reading it i'm like oh [ __ ]
walked up to him i was like
hey nick what are you doing he's like oh
doing some reading i was like anything
interesting he's like it's getting there
i was like i was like let me save you
the trouble
take the magazine turn over the page i
was like right there is what you're
looking for
he was like man i already knew
i was like
do we have a problem
and he looks at me it's like
is anyone on the compound you told on i
was like no he's like until someone gets
here you snitched on
we're okay
i was like
okay
he's like but
i need you to do something for me
all right so in federal prison you got
to have a job everybody works doesn't
matter what you do but you got to work i
got a job in education
teaching a lit class
every wednesday 6 8 30 p.m
lit and uh
had all
every area of the compound signs up for
the lit class had a couple guards every
now and then popped in and did we teach
lit
no
we talk fraud every wednesday 6 8 30 pm
that's how i didn't get my ass beaten
and my other job i had two jobs with
them the other job
you get to the point it's weird man you
get to the point
people walking off the bus
you know immediately two groups of
people you know who the bank robbers are
immediately just by them walking off the
bus they're like that motherfucker's a
bank robber and you know who the
pedophiles are immediately so my job as
the as the white guy was to approach the
white pedophiles and have a conversation
and the conversation was basically hey
don't know what you're in here for
don't care what you enter for
but
if you got some sort of [ __ ] up charge
you need to tell me
if you tell me everything's going to be
all right
if you don't tell me
you see those guys over there if you
start to associate with them or they
start to talk to you and then they find
out you're in here on something
they're going to kill you
and what other things pedophile
pedophile rapist anything that harms
children harms women anything like that
there are it's like the mob there's
rules there's there's an ethical code
even if you have the division between
races on all of that
you still have this these lines drawn
and what that is hierarchy too very very
much so what that looks like in prison
depending on the uh it depends on the
security class that you're in what what
what level prison but at that prison
what that looked like
was
you're not allowed to talk to anybody
you're not allowed to watch television
you can go to the library
you don't associate with anyone except
your own type
if you do anything like this we will
kill you
if we if someone wants to extort you
we will do that too
and you won't tell on us
or we'll kill you
so that's that's the way that works at
that point and everybody
quickly learns this quickly quickly and
uh so typically the guys would say i
just want to do my own time that would
be the line and it's like okay don't
mess with him all right um
every now and then you'd have somebody
lie
and that would come with those types of
consequences i got to see uh while i was
there
i saw two people murdered
saw went through three prison riots and
through my entire tenure in prison saw
four suicides
the people who got killed
it was so we had a outside you had this
track a third of a mile track you walk
it counterclockwise
and inside of the track you got two
handball courts so
of an evening it happened both times you
all of us would be walking you know
doing our exercises
and at the top of the key like a flock
of birds you'd see all the inmates start
to migrate down
toward the gate
so the first time you see that you see
that migration you look up in the
distance and this other that one
inmate's got another inmate down
and he's just hammering his head right
into the pavement like that right there
well guards don't stop that because the
guard may get hurt
so a guard is 15 minutes coming out to
stop that
until everything's over by that point
the guy doesn't have a head
they shut the compound down and this is
what happens so you shut the entire
compound down
they make two lines of the inmates and
what happens is inmate walks into a room
they shut the door behind the inmate
guard asks them two questions first
question is did you see anything the
answer is no
second question is if you had seen
anything would you say anything the
answer is no guard then says get the
[ __ ] out and that's it
anybody that stays in any longer than
that
is automatically suspect so there was
there was one instant i remember this
hispanic guy he's in there for a few
minutes
and everybody's like
what's going on
so his people then call him over explain
to us what went on yeah and it happens
like that it's fascinating that because
he talked about the network of trust
in the in the cyber crime community and
here's a network of trusts absolutely in
the prison crime community absolutely
and trust
trust trust matters
trust drives everything at the end of
the day the riots that i went through
the uh the first riot man you're scared
to death
scared to death you know you've got the
cops dressed up in the ninja turtle
outfits you've got the uh the rubber
bullets the tear gas canisters all that
crap you got the inmates that are raised
in hell
scared to death
the second riot
you calm down
second right you start to notice
this is racial riot this is typically
and almost always it's hispanics and
african americans so you get to you get
to detect what is the motivation for the
riot what's the reason and that gives
you some calm that's exactly right so
second round you start to notice this
hey man
this ain't me this ain't our group
third right no [ __ ] third right you're
laying your bunk
you let them rain you let them wake war
all around you and every now and then
you have an inmate they'll run up to you
and they'll point to a locker and say is
that your locker and if you tell them
yes they leave it alone if you say it's
not my locker they'll break into it and
steal everything out of it and go from
there
and that's what happens but uh so you
did your time for five years five and a
half five and a half
he made it out made it out i went
through uh the the i told you it was a
good lie that i told i went through the
residential drug abuse program it's a
nine month intensive therapy and uh the
way i got to that
this counselor at big spring he uh he
bought this
he wanted inmates to be educated he was
a really good guy so he wanted inmates
to be educated he got a discount
on a game theory class set
so he gets all these discounted and
everything and he's he's asking does
anybody on the compound know anything
about game theory and somebody says if
anybody does it'll be brett johnson so
he comes up to me one day at my bug he's
like are you brett johnson i was like
yeah he was like do you know anything
about game theory and i was like
yes i do
so i start rattling off prisoners
dilemma and everything else he's like
will you teach the class so i start
teaching that i start teaching inmates
uh public speaking
and make friends with this counselor
so i i get it gets time where i'm
supposed to be transferring out to this
drug program that they only had in fort
worth
and
the transfers are taking like four or
five months and that's four or five
months i could be out
free
so i walked i went up to him one day and
i was like look his name was keeley i
was like look man i said is there any
way
that i can get transferred out any
sooner and he looks at me he's like
brett i cannot help you
and i was like i appreciate that thank
you so much for even trying
so he said that a week later i'm on a
bus
by going to fort worth so he got support
i got it yeah i love it so it was a nine
month program uh 24 hours a day of
cognitive behavioral therapy had nothing
to do with drugs it was all peer peer
study stuff and cbt training
and
honestly it's the best thing that could
ever happen
you